prove how crazy these people have become
one more from MSNBC I apologize in
advance it's noted racist Joy Reed and
thankfully if you live near Joy read I
don't know where she lives I guess they
shoot that in New York right they shoot
that thing in New York so she probably
live somewhere in the tri-state area if
you were out and about celebrating on
July 4th fireworks hot dogs hamburgers
beer the whole thing music
you had no chance of seeing Joy Reid
because she stayed home during July 4th
because she's scared Hallelujah take a
look
Caroline light who literally wrote the
book on these laws writes for the Tampa
Bay Times that Florida has become the
stand your ground hellscape in which
lethal violence can be shoehorned into a
tidy Narrative of armed Good Guys
deflecting a multitude of suspicious bad
guys never mind that those presumed bad
guys often turn out to be pool cleaners
ride sharing customers furniture
delivery people and sometimes neighbors
um I have to say I did not go out on
July 4th and would not the idea of going
to a mass Gathering a parade or a big
fireworks thing outside seems insane to
me to be blunt in America because
America is Awash with guns and now
people don't just have them they seem to
want to shoot people with them and use
them for whatever you know yeah they're
just using guns forever uh we're
guessing by the backdrop there that
she's actually in DC not New York city
so in DC you know there is a good chance
you'd be shot uh this craziness where
she Associates everything with Florida
and guns and everything we did a little
research Brad Brock opened up the old
laptop we did a little research Fourth
of July weekend interestingly in Chicago
this was even for Chicago this is pretty
good 73 people were shot in Chicago 11
fatal interesting you don't know any of
their names there are no parades for any
of those people or anything because
virtually all of them were black shot by
black people so that doesn't fit the
narrative can't do that how many so
that's Chicago which has basically the
strictest gun laws in the entire uh
country Chicago of course is a city in a
state of Illinois how many people were
shot in Florida 14 in the entire State
uh one was fatal do you see the
difference there do you see the absolute
difference these people lie and then and
then you have this crazy psychotic
lunatic and that's the only way I can
describe her Joy Reed who is afraid of
going out because of gun violence
it is truly truly Wild
[Music]